this year's presidential election has
been one of the most contentious in
American history Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump have been at each other's
throats the entire campaign it has been
downright dirty now everybody is anxious
to see what will happen next Tuesday on
election day well guess what you don't
have to wait until then because we're
going to decide the president
presidential election right here
right now on the Apollo stage in a fight
to the death
building battle our first contender
hailing from right here on Fifth Avenue
in midtown Manhattan representing the
Republican Party who literally tripped
our
[Applause]
the Trump Tower weighing in and over 265
thousand tonnes it spans 58 stories and
has over 300 solid gold toilets our
second contender hailing from just over
35 miles outside New York City
representing the Democratic Party hits
Hillary Clinton's home in Chappaqua New
York
[Applause]
standing at three stories tall with five
bedrooms and four bathrooms this New
England styled home is located on a
tree-lined cul-de-sac
it features an entire barn filled with
private email servers with the Barrow
begin
[Applause]
hilary's home has broken into three
sections and surrounded Trump Tower
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hilary's guest house has joined the
fight these four and one it does not
look good for Trump
good for truck
[Applause]
House wins wins coming up and right back
[Applause]
you
you